America land of the free home of the
brave you feel some great things like
barbecue baseball a hip president but
here are some things you are doing
bloody wrong roundabouts you just don't
have enough of them
wouldn't you rather deal with this than
this food American pancakes
fluffy delicious but incredibly wrong
these are pancakes they are made in a
pan we even have a whole day for them
also your flapjacks are not flapjacks
these are flapjacks think of a better
version of a granola bar actually you're
doing a lot of foods wrong toast chips
crisps bangers pleasantries you're
wasting far too much time when talking
to friends
for instance you see a mate on the
street you go alright and they say all
right
conversation over it's great isn't it
instead of listing 20 reasons why you
can't do something just say to mate
I can't be bothered see easier slang
your slang is quite boring and not
nearly confusing enough so allow me to
kindly explain using in recent phrase so
what is a Nando's and why is it so
cheeky
so you're the lads after night out and
you're all like let's get Matthew DS but
your other mate is like nah let's get
cheeky Nando's instead it was like
brilliant so you go over cheeky Nando's
and a bit of top notch banner with the
lads still confused it's like say one
night you're out with your Bros and you
think let's go to McDonald's but your
friends are like no dude gotta step it
up a notch it's go I heart you have a
great time and you all go home happy
make sense
great what other things are Americans
doing wrong